es wird langsam eng für die europäische
union
übermorgen lädt brüssel zum
entscheidenden breaks it-gipfel und der
haushalt streit mit italien eskaliert
gerade total
wer rettet europa hoffentlich merkel und
mahkorn die sich neulich in frankreich
ja fast schon erschreckend nah gekommen
sind oder da wurden teilweise nasen
ohren geschrieben
es müsste übrigens [ __ ] aus sie heißen
so europas feinde
unsere feinde von innen und außen werden
immer stärker deswegen hat der
französische präsident jetzt bei seiner
rede im deutschen bundestag noch einmal
ein flammendes plädoyer für mehr europa
gehalten kam super an
das deutsch-französische hat lieblich
und die aufgabe die welt nicht ins chaos
abdriften zu lassen um aus dem euro eine
internationale währung mit einem
europäischen haushalt zu machen
das ist der sinn ich schaue mir jetzt
noch mal an geben sie mir noch einmal
ihre adresse aber ich nehme es trotzdem
noch mal auch aber ich kann ihn jetzt
hier nicht versprechen dass ich sie
zufrieden stellen
[Applaus]
ja
wir haben das material minimal
bearbeitet um merkels europapolitik ein
bisschen deutlicher zu machen
ein jahr lang hat deutschland gar nicht
geantwortet auf macros vorschläge
wirklich die merkel hat quasi das licht
ausgemacht und so getan als wäre sie
nicht zu hause
ja was ist denn übrig geblieben von
seinen großen ideen europäische armee in
ferner zukunft als vision sagt merkel
eigenes eurozone budget kammer machen
aber auch warum und viele länder sind
auch dagegen mein gott wie weit sollte
ich den manuel denn noch vor uns
deutschen erniedrigen getrübt dass sie
selbst wenn sie die wörter aus
frankreich nicht verstehen denken sie
daran die frankreich liebt sie gelesen
und hier ist es ein baguette oder freust
du dich mich zu sehen ist erwartet die
deutsche bevölkerung ist in umfragen so
deutlich pro europa wie lange nicht wie
lange nicht und kein land profitiert so
stark von binnenmarkt und euro wie wir
merkel muss also aus europa kanzlerin
endlich mal aus dem quark kommen und
zwar bevor es zu spät ist wenn man die
hat doch eh nichts mehr zu verlieren wir
brauchen jetzt ich weiß nicht große
worte die europas bürger emotional
packen entweder schaffen wir es
gemeinsame globale lösungen zu
erarbeiten schritt für schritt manchmal
zu langsam oder aber auch nicht
oder so wir schaffen das oder aber auch
nicht das macht mut dabei bräuchte man
ohne witz dringend eine positive vision
jemand den rechten gegnern der eu
entgegen setzen die haben nämlich einen
plan und sind schon hervorragend
vernetzt ja nur noch sechs monate vor
der europawahl beim großen europa
parteitag der fdp es gerade donnerndem
applaus für jeden redner der die zitat
zerschlagung der eu gefordert hat hier
der afg mann fest an die adresse von
emanuel makro fragen sie wird die ihre
landsleute ob die größere lasten
schultern wollen bis dann sollen alle
parasitären clowns einfach mal die
klappe halten die schmarotzer sollten
endlich mal lernen selbst zu arbeiten
jo parasitäre schmarotzer clowns aus
deiner nachbarschaft wollen nicht
arbeiten
eines der größten probleme unserer zeit
also nach den wisenten natürlich ist
klar der sogenannte europa der
vaterländer ist der feuchte retro traum
aller europäischen rechtspopulisten und
was das konkret heißt kann man jetzt
auch spielerisch lernen spiele
präsentiert das große puzzle der
vaterländer für diese kleine rechte aus
ganz europa ihr startet mit einem
vereinten und solidarischen kontinent
und deswegen machen wir ihn einfach
kaputt
zuerst aus black city bei madonnas polen
ungarn tschechien österreich alle keinen
bock mehr auf italien total pleite aber
dazu wieder mit leber und dann reißt er
den ganzen restlichen scheiß auseinander
bis jeder nur noch sein vaterland hat
und fragt doch nicht so blöd du kleiner
makkaroni ihr habt europa zerlegt jetzt
könnt ihr euch wieder gegenseitig
verprügeln dass größe der vorkommen
die 65 euro auf den konzerten
wieso das europa der vaterländer
aktive ski meine schon allein die
tatsache dass trump und putin die eu
weghaben wollen beweist doch dass man
für sie kämpfen muss jetzt ist der
zeitpunkt und gerade jungen menschen
sollte man erklären was das für eine
einmalige errungenschaft ist eine
historische errungenschaft und das
versucht jetzt carolin kebekus bei
youtube ist beauty und europatage hey
leute ich bin echt so ein riesen fan von
europa wirklich gut mal dem motto
[Musik]
und diese frau jahr die vor eingelegt
mit falschen versprechungen und so quasi
der umgedrehte enkeltrick dabei hält
sich ständig mit mag letztens hat sogar
eine 101 jährige französin gedacht die
merkel wer die frau format
zwei sieger
mehr
zu bringen schon zu je drei mann ja das
ist englisch und bedeutet soviel wie oma
wälze mich beleidigen die frau von
makros soviel elber europa so viel
gerade für junge leute geben zum
beispiel die roaming gebühren
abgeschafft seitdem rufe ich den ganzen
tag wildfremde leute einfach nur weil
ich kann bundschuh arrivederci baku oder
interrail gibt's was geileres leute wer
mal den budapest oder barcelona am
hauptbahnhof wach geworden ist der weiß
europa zu schätzen
du warst erst wirklich in europa wenn du
in budapest in deiner eigenen kotze
aufgewacht ist ich habe damals nicht bis
nach budapest geschafft ich war schon in
bielefeld ohnmächtig die eben das ist
mir datenschutz umweltschutz und
verbraucherrechte ein bier das in einem
eu staat angeboten wird darf auch in
allen anderen verkauft werden so wie
meine eigene kraft bier linie daraus
obergäriges starkbier mit lieber was
banane geschmack stark aber bekommen
ähnlich ein wie europa aber vor allem
europa ist ein friedensprojekt noch nie
hat es bei uns so lange frieden am stück
gegeben hier mein opa hat zwei
weltkriege verloren rissen sensibles
thema der russe ist wieder da
[Musik]
[Applaus]